>> Sean: YES, SIR.
GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS, TUCKER.
THANK YOU, WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
FOX NEWS, MOVES AWAY, THE
PRESIDENT WILL JOIN US FOR AN
EXCLUSIVE ONE-ON-ONE INTERVIEW,
FULL, COMPLETE REACTION TO ALL
OF THE EVENTS YESTERDAY OF
COURSE, THE SQUAD, YOU DON'T
WANT TO MISS IT.
IT HAS BEEN A VERY GOOD DAY, TWO
DAYS TO THE PRESIDENT AND
ACTUALLY, GREAT DAYS FOR
AMERICA.
HORRIBLE DAY IF YOU ARE A PART
OF THE CORRUPT STATE IN ONE OF
THEIR OPERATIVES AND THE LYING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND THE
TRUMPET MOB.
HERE'S THE REALITY, THEY JUST
SEEM INCAPABLE OF ACCEPTING
WHICH IS, I THINK I'M AT THE
FOUNDATION OF WHY THEY KEEP
GOING HERE.
THEY CAN'T ACCEPT THE 2016
ELECTION RESULTS.
DONALD TRUMP ONE, THEY DIDN'T
ANTICIPATE IT, HE IS THE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
THE RUSSIA HOAX, THOSE LIES,
THEY ARE DEAD AND BURIED AND NOW
THE PEOPLE WHO ABUSED POWER THAT
WERE CORRUPT THAT BROKE THE LAW
WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
IT'S REALLY THAT SIMPLE.
ALL OF THESE IMPEACHMENT
FANTASIES ARE TOTALLY COMPLETELY
FLUSHED DOWN THE DRAIN.
THANK GOD.
TRUTH PREVAILED.
THIS WAS A DANGEROUS MOMENT FOR
THIS COUNTRY.
YESTERDAY'S HEARING WAS A
DISASTER FOR THE RADICAL
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE RAGING
PSYCHOTIC TRUMP HATING LUNATICS
IN THE VIDEO MOB, TONIGHT, THEY
HAVE NOBODY BUT TO BLAME FOR
THIS BUT THEMSELVES.
THAT INCLUDES THE DEMOCRATS LIKE
SCHIFF AND NADLER AND PRETTY
MUCH EVERYONE ELSE IN THE
WASHINGTON SWAMP.
MANY PEOPLE KNEW ROBERT MUELLER
WAS NOT ON TOP OF HIS GAME.
WE ALL SAW THE NINE MINUTE
PRESSER.
HE LITERALLY CONTRADICTED HIS
FINDINGS OF OBSTRUCTION.
RIGHT IN FRONT OF US.
THEY SAW HIM STRUGGLING, THEY
SAW THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR
BAILED HIM OUT WITH THE JOINT
STATEMENT AT THE SPECIAL
COUNSELOR'S OFFICE.
THEY KNEW THAT HE WAS SAYING
DON'T CALLED ME AND THEY DID IT
ANYWAY.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO APPEAR BEFORE
CONGRESS.
HE WANTED HIS REPORT TO
BASICALLY BE HIS REPORT.
THEY KNEW HIS TESTIMONY PROP WAS
GOING BADLY.
I KNEW HIS TESTIMONY PROPYL AND
HIS LAW FIRM WAS GOING BADLY
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS IK
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS IO
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS I,
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS II
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS IM
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS IP
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS IE
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS IT
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS IY
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS IC
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS IR
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS IA
FROM THE SOURCES I HAD BUT AS IN
THEY ALL KNEW IT TOO.
BUT HE IS A REALITY CHECK FOR
THEM.
THEY DIDN'T CARE.
THEY WERE DETERMINED TO USE
MUELLER AT A LATER STAGE IN HIS
LEG.
THERE IS NO DISS ON
ROBERT MUELLER AT ALL.
AS A POLITICAL PROP THOUGH, THEY
DID THAT.
ONE LAST TIME, THEY WERE HOPING
HE WAS GOING TO SAY ONE THING
THAT HE COULD USE TO JUST HONE
IN HERE TO SMEAR, SLANDER, JUST
MERGED THE PRESIDENT, SPUR
IMPEACHMENT, THEIR GOAL.
IT WAS ABSOLUTE FAILURE AND
FRANKLY, PAINFUL AT TIMES TO
WATCH.
MUELLER DID NOT HAVE A GRASP ON
SOME OF THE MOST BASIC ELEMENT
OF HIS OWN REPORT.
HE HAD A DIFFICULT TIME TRACKING
QUESTIONS OR REMEMBERING ANY OF
THE DETAILS OF THE REPORT.
HE CONTRADICTED HIMSELF ON THE
REPORT ON NUMEROUS OCCASIONS.
AS POLITICO PUT IT, MUELLER WAS
STRUGGLING.
NOW, CONFIRMATION THAT WE WILL
RIGHT ALL ALONG.
IT WAS NOTHING MORE THAN
FRANKLY, SO SHE DREW THE END OF
THIS LEASE, A SYMBOLIC
FIGUREHEAD IN A SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S PRO.
HE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT
HILLARY CLINTON'S FORMER
ATTORNEY WAS ON HIS STAFF?
ANDREW WEISSMANN, HIS PITBULL,
THE GUY WHO HAD TO HILLARY'S
VICTORY OF PARTY, DID ALL THE
HIRING, HE DIDN'T KNOW THEY WERE
ALL DEMOCRATS?
HE DIDN'T KNOW THAT REAGAN HAD
GIVEN HIM AN APPOINTMENT?
HE DIDN'T KNOW FUSION GPS?
HE DIDN'T CARE THAT BEFORE THAT
SO CALLED FAMOUS TRUMP TOWER
MEETING THAT FUSION GPS MET WITH
THE RUSSIAN OPERATIVES?
BEFORE AND AFTER THE MEETING?
IN OTHER WORDS, FOR 20 MONTHS,
DEMOCRATS USED MUELLER'S A SO
POLITICAL REPUTATION, HE IS A
DECORATED MARINE, HE DID SERVE
THIS COUNTRY AND IN.
A LONG SERVING FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR USING HIM FOR
LEGITIMIZING THEIR PARTISAN
WHICH CAN'T, CARING NOTHING
ABOUT THE PERSON AT ALL.
IT SEEMS THAT THERE WAS REALLY
PUBLICLY ONLY ONE PERSON THAT
CARED ABOUT ROBERT MUELLER.
KEPT TRYING TO THROW HIM A
LIFELINE.
KEPT TRYING TO PROTECT HIS
REPUTATION.
KNOWING THIS WOULD GO BADLY.
I DON'T THINK ATTORNEY WAS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR.
AND HE WAS SLANDERED AND SMEARED
FOR IT.
SOMETHING WAS UP WHEN HE VERY
GRACIOUSLY AGREED TO THE JOINT
STATEMENT.
IT JUST DIDN'T TRACK RIGHT IN MY
BRAIN.
HILLARY CLINTON SUPER FAN, THE
GUY AT THE VICTORY PARTY,
ANDREW WEISSMANN, THE PEOPLE,
THIS IS THE GUY THAT SIDNEY
POWELL WROTE ABOUT IN LICENSE TO
LIVE.
THE MOST ATROCIOUS PROSECUTORIAL
TRACK RECORD I HAVE EVER HEARD
OF, LIKELY RUNNING THE SHOW FROM
DAY ONE, WHICH ACTUALLY, MAKES
THE CONCLUSION EVEN THAT MUCH
MORE REMARKABLE HERE YESTERDAY,
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED THAT TRUTH
IS A FORCE OF NATURE.
HE WAS RIGHT.
THE LAST HOAX HAS BEEN EXPOSED
REACTION, EVEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STUMBLED ON
SOME TRUTH.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
WHEN THEY REPORTED THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS PROBABLY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION FROM THE GET-GO,
WHAT WERE THEY REALLY SAYING
THERE?
THAT MEANS, WITHOUT SAYING IT,
THEY INADVERTENTLY WERE SAYING
THAT IF THE RUSSIANS WERE
INVOLVED FROM THE BEGINNING, AND
THEY KNEW ABOUT DEAL READING
THIS TO HILLARY, THEY SAY, THAT
IT WAS LIKELY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION FROM THE GECKO,
THAT MEANS THAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE NOT HELPING HILLARY CLINTON
IN THE 2016 ELECTION.
THAT WOULD MEAN THEY WERE TRYING
TO SCREW OVER DONALD TRUMP AND
GET HILLARY ELECTED.
NOW, AN INVESTIGATION INTO THE
ORIGINS OF THIS WITCH HUNT IS
WELL UNDERWAY BUT AS WE SPEAK,
THE CONSPIRACY THEORIST ON MSDN
C, FAKE NEWS CNN, THEY ARE
RACKED WITH GRIEF.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THERE IS NO REMORSE FOR LYING TO
THEIR VIEWERS FOR MORE THAN 20
YEARS FOR THEY ARE JUST SOW THE
GIG IS OUT.
THEY'VE BEEN CAUGHT SPREADING A
BASELESS HOAX, CONSPIRACY THEORY
AFTER CONSPIRACY THEORY, HERE'S
MY PRODUCTION ON THE MEDIA.
SABOT IT'LL BE TRUE, IT WILL
NEVER APOLOGIZE TO THEIR
AUDIENCES, SHRINKING AS THEY
ARE, THEY WILL NEVER INSTITUTE
CHANGES.
THEY WILL NEVER JUST MOVE ON TO
THE TRUTH AND GATHERING TRUTH
THE END OF HER BECOMING A REAL
NEWS ORGANIZATION.
THEY WILL MOVE ONTO THE NEXT TOT
THEY WILL MOVE ONTO THE NEXT TOO
A MUTUALLY WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS WHO FEED THEM
INFORMATION.
IT'S A BIG INSIDER CYCLE THAT
THEY HAVE.
AND THEY WILL SPREAD ALL THE
TALKING POINTS THAT NOW SPEND
EVERY SECOND, EVERY MINUTE,
EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY TRYING
TO DESTROY PRESIDENT TRUMP AT
ALL COST.
THAT IS THEIR MISSION.
SO TONIGHT, THERE ARE SOME OF
THE MEDIA MOB, THEY ARE CLEARLY
AGENT DEJECTED BEARD OTHERS ARE
ENRAGED.
OR AT LEAST, THEY ARE FEIGNING
BEING IN RAGE.
BUT MOST ARE STILL IN COMPLETE
DENIAL.
I FIRST DECLARED THE MEDIA
JOURNALISM AND AMERICA'S DEAD IN
2007.
DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS AS RED AS I
WAS AT THE TIME.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S SHAMEFUL.
SHAMEFUL THAT REPUBLICANS WERE
SO FOCUSED ON TRYING TO
UNDERMINE THE ORIGINS OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> THEY WERE VERY DISRESPECTFUL,
I THOUGHT, THE REPUBLICANS.
THEY WE HAVE A TENDENCY TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL TO VETERANS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: LET'S NOT KID
OURSELVES PRAYED THIS HAS BEEN A
WALL-TO-WALL FAILURE IN ALL OF
THESE COMMITTEES.
SPEAK ABOUT INSTINCT FOR
WINNING, THAT SORT OF CONTROLLED
RAGE THAT YOU WANT GREAT
ATHLETES TO HAVE BEFORE THEY GO
OUT INTO THE FIELD, THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT DEMOCRATS LACK.
IT IS NOT IN THEIR DNA AND IT IS
SO FRUSTRATING.
YOU KNOW DAWN?
HERE'S THE DEAL.
I MAY NOT WIN BUT NEITHER WILL
YOU BECAUSE I'M GOING TO SPEND
24 HOURS A DAY, SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK WORKING, FOCUSING, NOT
GOING TO SLEEP UNTIL I FIGURE
OUT HOW TO TURN YOUR POLITICAL
BONES TO DUST.
>> Sean: ASKING FOR
FORGIVENESS FOR EVER BEING A
REPUBLICAN.
OKAY.
AFTER TWO YEARS OF CLAIMING THE
PRESIDENT WAS A RUSSIAN
OPERATIVES, WORKING WITH AND FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN, WHO STOLE THE
ELECTION ENDS, THAT'S WHAT YOU
GET.
THE SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS AND
NEWSROOMS ALL AROUND AMERICA
WITHOUT EXCEPTION, HAD ANY
COURAGE OR DECENCY AT ALL,
THEY WOULD APOLOGIZE TO YOU,
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR
THEIR LINE, THEIR HOPES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES BUT THEY
WON'T.
IT'S CLEAR THEY HATES IT, THINK
ABOUT THIS, WHAT ARE THEY REALLY
HATE IN THIS, TOO?
HALF THE COUNTRY?
SMALLEY, WALMART, DEPLORABLE
TRUMP VOTERS.
ANGRY, BUT HE BETTER PEOPLE IN
PENNSYLVANIA THAT CLAIMED TWO
GODS, GUNS, BIBLES, AND
RELIGION?
WHAT A SANCTIMONY THEN THERE IS
A LOT OF ELITISM AND ALL THOSE
WORDS, IS IN A QUESTION LIKE
THIS HATRED DOES CLOUD THEIR
JUDGMENT WHICH IS WHY THEY HAVE
BEEN WRONG ABOUT SO MUCH SO
OFTEN.
WE ON THIS SHOW, WE TAKE GREAT
PRIDE.
WHEN ALWAYS RIGHT, WE WILL ADMIT
WHEN WE ARE WRONG BUT WE WORK
HARD TO GET EVERYTHING RIGHT
HERE AND WE ALMOST
SINGLE-HANDEDLY VENT OBAMA.
WE WERE RIGHT ABOUT THE CROSS
CASE.
I WENT AND MET WITH THE KIDS AND
THE FAMILIES.
WHAT ABOUT ABOUT UBA, FERGUSON,
MISSOURI.
BALTIMORE, THEY CAN TAKE IT
BACK, I LEARNED MY LESSON WITH
RICHARD JEWELL PAID I WAS ONLY
WHEN I WAS RIGHT ON THAT CASE.
LOOK AT NICHOLAS SANDMANN.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY DID TO THAT
KID FOR WEARING MAKE AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN HAD HER LOOK AT WHAT
THEY DID TO BRETT KAVANAUGH.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE MUCH
ABOUT BELIEVING WHEN IT COMES TO
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF THE
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA.
ON COURSE, THEY WERE WRONG ON
THE RUSSIAN HOAX AND THE LIST
GOES ON AROUND YOU THAT BRINGS
US BACK TO THE MEDIA'S FAVORITE
HACK AND THAT WOULD BE THE
COWARDLY ADAM SCHIFF.
I OFFERED HIM FOUR HOURS OF
AIRTIME.
AN HOUR OF TV, THREE HOURS ON
620 OF THE BEST RADIO STATIONS
IN AMERICA.
HE NEVER GETS BACK TO ME.
NOT COME OVER THE COURSE OF
TRUMP'S RESIDENCY, SHIFT HAS
PARTICIPATED, LOOK AT THIS, 419
TV INTERVIEWS.
419.
NOT ON THIS SHOW.
HE ACTUALLY SPREAD REAL
CONSPIRACY THEORIES ABOUT
RUSSIA, CREATED FALSE HOPE IN
ALL OF THESE LIBERALS AND ALL OF
THOSE RESISTED MEMBERS.
BUT DESPITE MANY OFFERS TO COME
ON HIS PROGRAM FOR THE FULL ALL
OVER, HE ALWAYS DECLINES.
THE COWARDLY SHIFT KNEW HE WAS
FULL OF B.S. PEERED HE KNEW HE
WAS LYING.
HE KEPT RAISING THE BAR, BAR,
EXHORTATIONS, HE SAID I'VE SEEN
IT.
WE GOT THE EVIDENCE.
WE DON'T.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET SCHIFF IS A
CARD.
WE SUDDENLY COME AFTER MUELLER'S
DISASTROUS TESTIMONY, WHICH WAS
A POLITICAL STUNT ALL ALONG, WE
HAVE PURE RAW UGLY COMMENTS
NEARING, JUST MERGING,
SLANDERING, DESTROYING OF NAMES
AND REPUTATIONS, WE KNEW ALL
ALONG, HE JUST BACKS AWAY FROM
HIS IMPEACHMENT DREAMS.
NEVER MIND.
AFTER TELLING THE COUNTRY FOR
THREE YEARS HE HAD THE EVIDENCE,
PROVE THE PRESIDENT WAS A
RUSSIAN OUTCOME OF THE
GOVERNMENT WAS IN CRISIS, HE IS
JUST CONTENT NOW TO WAIT FOR THE
2020 ELECTION.
SO THIS IS JUST A POLITICAL
GAIN.
THIS IS WHAT WE GET FROM THE
PEOPLE WE SEND TO WASHINGTON.
ALL THIS FAKE, PHONY, SELECTIVE
MORAL OUTRAGE AND NOW, WE GOT
THAT FROM THE BEGINNING.
NOW, TONIGHT, SCHIFF IS IN VERY
GOOD COMPANY.
THE NEW LEADERS OF THE SPECIAL
RADICAL SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC
PARTY KNOWN AS THE SQUAD, THEY
ARE NO STRANGERS TO FAKE MORAL
OUTRAGE HERE THEY ARE CONSTANTLY
CALLING FOR THE PRESIDENT TO BE
IMPEACHED.
RECENTLY, CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR
CALLED TRUMP A RACIST WHO WANTS
TO DEPORT ALL BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE HERE THAT IS OF COURSE A
BLATANT LIE.
JUST THIS WEEK WE LEARNED THAT
IT WAS FATAL SQUAD MEMBER,
CONGRESSMAN KHALIL BAHUJAN
CALLED FOR THE DEPORTATION OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON TWITTER, IN W
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON TWITTER, IN I
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON TWITTER, IN G
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON TWITTER, IN A
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON TWITTER, IN D
IT TURNS OUT THE SQUAD'S
FAKE MORAL OUTRAGE IS JUST A
COVER-UP FOR THEIR OWN
DEEP-SEATED BIGOTRY AND EXTREME
RADICAL VIEWS THAT WE ARE NOW
EXPOSING EVERY DAY.
ESPECIALLY, WHEN IT COMES TO
ISRAEL.
EACH MEMBER OF THE SQUAD
SUPPORTS SOME FORM OF THE
BOYCOTT OF ISRAEL.
A WIDESPREAD BOYCOTT WITH ANSI
SOMATIC COMMENTS AND ROUTES TO
BACK IT UP.
AND AS YOU KNOW BY NOW,
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR HAS REFERRED
TO ISRAEL AS EVIL.
SHE SAYS THEY HAVE BEEN HAS A
WORLDVIEW SHE COMPARED THE
WORLD'S ONLY JEWISH STATES TO
HIM THE HOLOCAUST.
NAZI GERMANY.
AND BELIEVE IT OR NOT, JUST TO
SPEAK, CONGRESSWOMAN TO LEAVE
DID THE SAME THING.
REALLY?
YOU ARE GOING TO COMPARE ISRAEL
TO MASS MURDERING THE IN
GERMANY?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I CAN'T STAND BY AND WATCH
THIS ATTACK ON OUR FREEDOM OF
SPEECH AND THE RIGHT TO BOYCOTT
THE RACIST POLICIES OF THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE OF
ISRAEL.
AMERICANS OF CONSCIENCE HAVE
LONG AND PROUD HISTORY OF
PARTICIPATING IN BOYCOTTS,
SPECIFICALLY TO ADVOCATE FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS ABROAD.
AMERICANS BOYCOTTED NAZI GERMANY
IN RESPONSE TO DEHUMANIZATION,
IMPRISONMENT, AND OF JEWISH
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: ISRAEL IS NOT THE
ONLY TARGET OF THE SQUADS
INTERVIEWED RECENTLY, OMAR SAID
THAT AMERICAN SHOULD BE MORE
FEARFUL OF WHITE MEN.
WOW.
DON'T FORGET, WILL CAUSE YOUR
CONTEST AS WE ARE A GARBAGE
COUNTRY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> OUR COUNTRY SHOULD BE MORE
FEARFUL OF WHITE MEN ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY ARE
ACTUALLY CAUSING MOST OF THE
DEATHS WITHIN THIS COUNTRY AND
SO, IF THE FEAR WAS THE DRIVING
FORCE OF POLICIES TO KEEP
AMERICA SAFE, AMERICANS SAFE,
INSIDE OF THIS COUNTRY, WE
SHOULD BE PROFILING AND
MONITORING AND CREATING POLICIES
TO FIGHT THE RADICALIZATION OF
WHITE MEN.
>> Sean: WHITE MEN.
IN REALITY, WE SHOULD BE MOST
FEARFUL OF THE SQUADS RADICAL
SOCIALIST IDEOLOGY.
IT WILL DESTROY THIS COUNTRY.
AND I MEAN, VERY QUICKLY PAIR
THE NEW GREEN DEAL, NO OIL, GAS,
TILL HE WANTS A $20 MINIMUM
WAGE.
$5 HIGHER THAN BERNIE.
BERNIE SANDERS IS ALSO
SUPPORTING THE GRAY NEW DEAL.
SOCIAL TRANSFORMATION OF AMERICA
BECAUSE OF HOW HOT IT IS THE
SUMMER AND ASHLEY, SHE'S ALSO
CALLING FOR YOUR TAX CUTS TO BE
REPEALED SO SHE CAN GIVE YOUR
HARD-EARNED MONEY TO THE PEOPLE
WHO REALLY DESERVE IT.
THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID.
>> RECENTLY, INTRODUCED THE
BOOST ACT.
THIS LEGISLATION COMPLETELY
REPEALS THE G.O.P. TAX SCAM.
THAT IS ONLY HELPING WHILE THE
INDIVIDUALS, THE RICH, THE
CORPORATIONS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I DID WITHOUT
MONEY?
DO YOU KNOW NASI?
NO.
WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND PUT
IT INTO THE POCKETS OF FOLKS
LIKE EVERYDAY AMERICANS.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO WITH OUR
PUBLIC DOLLARS PAID WE GIVE IT
BACK TO THE PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE EARNED IT.
>> Sean: TAKE IT, STEAL, AND
GIVE IT AWAY.
WELL, SO, JUST WHO DESERVES YOUR
HARD-EARNED MONEY?
HERE'S AN IDEA.
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR NOW CALLING
FOR TAXPAYER-FUNDED ABORTIONS
WERE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, LOOK
CLOSELY BECAUSE THESE ARE THE
LEADERS OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NOW, THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
HAVING THE MOST IMPACT ON THE
2020 DEMOCRATIC HOPEFULS.
THEY ARE THE ONES WOULD'VE
GOTTEN EVERYONE OF THEM TO BUY
INTO SOME ORIGIN OF THIS INSANE
GREEN NEW DEAL.
AND BY THE WAY, THIS PARTICULAR
HOUR, IT'S NOT PELOSI SPEAKER
NAME ONLY BUT YOU HAVE
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR, TLAIB, CASIO
KURT HAS, AND PRESLEY ALL BEING
CHEERED ON BY THE RADICAL DAYS,
INCLUDING THE FAR LEFT CROWD IN
HOLLYWOOD.
ANTI-TRUMP HYSTERIA ON THE
WEST COAST, THEY ARE AT A
FEVERED PITCH.
MANY IN THE FILM INDUSTRY
BECOMING LITERALLY UNRAVELED.
TAKE, FOR EXAMPLE, REMEMBER THIS
GUY WHO WORKS IN FAKE NEWS CNN,
HE JUST SAID THE DEVIL WORK.
WORSHIPERS WERE BETTER THAN
TRUMP SUPPORTER'S.
THEN AS BETH MIDLER, ONSET OF
ACTUALLY MAKING MOVIES, SHE NOW
SPENDS HER DAYS RAGED WEEDING
THE PRESIDENT, LIKE THE MEDIA,
BUT YESTERDAY WHEN SHE TRY TO
PUT -- THE PRESIDENT, SHE
ACTUALLY TWEETED OUT SOMETHING
RACIST, YIKES.
SHE POSTED THIS PICTURE OF A
TRUMP RALLY WITH THE QUESTION
WITH THE CAPTION, "LOOK, THERE
ARE AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEN AND THE
SHOT.
HOW DID IT MUCH DID THEY PAY
THEM TO BE IN THE BACKGROUND?"
>> MAYBE NOBODY TOLD HER THAT WE
HAVE THE BEST EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION SINCE 1969 AND A
RECORD LOW AND EMPLOYMENT
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
BACK IN THEIR AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, AND YOUTH AND
EMPLOYMENT.
THAT HAPPENED BECAUSE OF
DONALD TRUMP'S POLICIES.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN UNDER BIDEN
OBAMA.
BETH MIDLER THINKING THE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, WHAT, THEY
CAN HAVE DIFFERING INDEPENDENT
POLITICAL VIEWS?
PRETTY DESPICABLE TO DESPICABLE,
DISGUSTING, VILE, AND RACIST AND
THAT NO ONE IN HOLLYWOOD IS ABLE
TO CALL HER OUT ISN'T SHOCKING.
EVERY SINGLE TWO OR FOUR YEARS,
BEING RACIST, SEXIST,
HOMOPHOBIC, XENOPHOBIC,
ISLAMOPHOBIC, WANTING TO THROW
CHILDREN AND THROW GRANNY OVER
THE CLIFF AFTER SHE EATS DOG
FOOD AND CAT FOOD, WELL, THAT IS
OUT THERE TO BUY SO MANY PEOPLE
ON THE LEFT.
I THINK WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE AND IT COULD BE SUMMED UP
IN JUST THREE WORDS.
FAKE MORAL OUTRAGE.
MIDLER, HOLLYWOOD FRIENDS, THEY
DON'T CARE ABOUT RACISM, SICK
SEXISM, XENOPHOBIA, OR ANY OF
THIS UNLESS THEY CAN BLUDGEON
TRUMP OR A POLITICAL ALLEY OF TE
PRESIDENT.
OR A CONSERVATIVE.
IN THE END, THAT MIDLER IS JUST
THE PERFECT REPRESENTATION OF
TODAY'S RADICAL LEFT.
HE HATES THE PRESIDENT, HIS
SUPPORTERS, NEVER TALKS ABOUT